The Terminator has spawned an entire entertainment
franchise, one that includes films, TV series,
and now-defunct amusement park attractions.
But, as with any franchise out there, not
all installments are created equal.
Here's how the films and shows stack up, from
worst to best.
The Terminator franchise had already put out
two immensely successful releases by 2003,
when Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines came
out.
It marked the first film without any involvement
from series creator James Cameron.
It shows.
Rise of the Machines is all style and zero
substance, one of those films that throws
everything that worked from its predecessors
at the wall and winds up making a giant mess
with it.
The chases are bigger, but definitely not
better.
Somehow, more explosions happen than in either
previous movie, but they don't seem to be
there for any reason other than someone decided
it was a Terminator movie, and Terminator
movies need explosions.
Rise of the Machines is basically the same
movie as Judgment Day, only with a female
Terminator chasing after John Connor while
Arnold Schwarzenegger's T-800 attempts to
protect him.
Just prior to the release of 2009's Terminator
Salvation, Machinima released this tie-in
web series.
Terminator Salvation: The Machinima Series
takes place in 2016, two years prior to the
events of Salvation the movie, and it centers
on Blair Williams as she sets out on a mission
to hunt down "the Ghost," a hacker who’s
interfering with Resistance communications.
If you can get past the mediocre effects,
The Machinima Series manages to be a pretty
entertaining series.
It doesn't add anything or take away from
the franchise, the story doesn't affect the
greater Skynet threat in the long run, but
it gets points for creativity.
And out of all the Terminator films, the fact
that Salvation managed to be the one to get
its own offshoot web series as a marketing
ploy is pretty daring.
Following up Rise of the Machines, Terminator
Salvation tells the bleak, post-Judgment Day
story of the Resistance and its fighters.
There were hopes that the film would reinvigorate
the franchise, and for a time, it seemed as
though it would.
Jonathan Nolan, the award-winning writer behind
The Dark Knight, Interstellar, and HBO's Westworld,
had started work on the script but pulled
out due to another commitment.
Then there was a writers’ strike.
Salvation just couldn't seem to catch a break.
In 2018, star Christian Bale appeared on MTV's
Happy Sad Confused podcast and touched on
his regrets.
Bale said:
"I said no three times.
And it's a great thorn in my side, because
I wish we could have reinvigorated that.
And unfortunately, during production, you
could tell that wasn't happening.
But it's a great shame."
At least Salvation isn't another retelling
of the first three films.
In this one, John Connor is a fully-fledged
resistance leader, Kyle Reese is a young,
pre-time traveling Sarah Connor-romancer,
and the main cyborg doesn't even know he's
a machine.
"Who built you?"
"My name is Marcus Wright."
"You think you're human?"
"I am human."
Terminator Genisys
Terminator Genisys, the 2015 franchise reboot,
was supposed to be the film that really would
bring fans back to the fold.
Even James Cameron told Yahoo!
Movies that he felt as though Genisys worked
as the true third installment in the Terminator
franchise.
With a story centered on fractured timelines
and unexpected villains, Genisys really is
the best film to come out since Terminator
2.
But saying that it's better than the two films
before it isn't really saying much at all.
The most successful thing about Genisys is
the way it treats its source material.
Using a combination of fancy CGI work and
reenactments with body doubles who look just
enough like the '84 actors to get by, Genisys
pays a great deal of fan service to those
who loved the original.
Where it fails is in trying to weave in new
material.
Nearly everything that takes place in the
new 2017 timeline is confusing, but seeing
a 1984 Sarah Connor kick ass kind of makes
up for it.
For two seasons, The Sarah Connor Chronicles
gave fans hope that the franchise could, in
fact, get back on track.
Taking place after the events of Terminator
2, the series sees Sarah and a teenage John
Connor running from yet another Terminator,
with the help of a cyborg named Cameron.
Get it?
Cameron?
The Sarah Connor Chronicles jumps in time
from 1997 to 2007, effectively erasing Rise
of the Machines.
Sarah and John are able to exist in a timeline
more in line with Terminator 2.
Sarah is still alive and a key figure in the
Resistance.
Star Lena Headey manages to pick up where
Linda Hamilton left off in a way that feels
more like an homage to the original character
than someone trying to replace her.
Just before The Terminator hit theaters in
1984, Orion studio execs refused to screen
it for critics, showing little confidence
in it.
The lack of love from the studio at the time
stuck with Cameron for over three decades,
but looking at the film now, it's impossible
to imagine how anyone could consider it a
failure.
And thankfully, audiences at the time felt
the same way.
The Terminator launched Cameron's career as
a director and Arnold Schwarzenegger's as
an actor.
It was like nothing that had ever happened
in movies, and it proved that audiences were
willing to shell out their hard-earned money
to watch a diner waitress and her time-traveling
boyfriend get chased through the streets of
Los Angeles by a cyborg in leather.
Cameron told the audience at the fifth annual
Hero Complex Film Festival that the fearlessness
it took to make The Terminator came from his
frustration in trying to break into the industry.
He said:
"I was the anonymous, kind of angry, wannabe
filmmaker.
There's some courage that comes from that,
you say whatever comes into your head…I
was kind of like a free voice in the wilderness
in that stage."
Terminator 2: Judgment Day not only builds
upon the world created by its predecessor,
but it's also somehow better than the original
movie.
Over ten years after the events of The Terminator,
Sarah Connor has been institutionalized because
of her belief in time-traveling killer robots.
Her son, John, lives with foster parents.
The original T-800 has been reprogrammed as
a protector for John, and the new evil is
the T-1000, an updated Terminator with the
added feature of shape-shifting liquid metal.
Judgment Day isn't just a continuation of
the series, it's something totally new.
Sarah is a fighting machine, a far cry from
the scared waitress in The Terminator.
The T-800 is no longer a threat, and this
version of the character sets up a multi-movie
arc for the original big bad, one that sees
an aging actor continue to reprise the role,
in spite of the fact that robots shouldn't
age.
Judgment Day's T-800 was just so likable,
it didn’t matter.
Plus, it gave us some fantastic catchphrases.
"Hasta la vista, baby."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.